passé en trois mois je rêve
[Musique]
enfin
ans
[Musique]
une fois pris froid et oui c'est frais
voire froid il fait froid et froid et
les vrais fruits
ouais mais je ne suis pas 30 secondes
ont déjà clairement sur la position d'un
retard parce que c'est mon préféré
nous n'allons tout cela mais on sort et
mamy blue je n'en rêve de la portable
[Musique]
j'ai passé en trois points
le régime mais c'est comme ça que j'ai
mis les mobiles sur ses os mineur à
présent
il ya des jeunes qui passent et c'est
une partie qui a tendance à michel jau
par 27 à paupières je regarde en l'air
tu lis toujours compter sur laden qui
est immobile qui mobilise les placer
dans l'oeil genre du western
et bien c'est que si le mec j'ai insulté
ce matin à paris en faisant mes
meilleurs souvenirs c'est moi car ça
[Musique]
la matière c'est ça j'appuie gspr et
voilà alors je vois ça bon jour vers un
salon d'esthéticienne
je vais pas hésiter à l'ouvrir à quatre
fois pour de bon
plus vous allez pouvoir envoyer vos
créations de saper a pris aux réseaux
sociaux et en 2d sera plus grande nous
avons être une amie et 2
[Musique]